obviously you're upset I'm sad David
you're not you've been sitting over
there with your arms crossed looking hit
stop for the past couple hours so and I
guess I'm upset so you aren't saying
where you going where am I going I am
going to leave because you obviously
haven't figured out if you're upset or
not so when you do you can give me a
call but until then I'm leaving - you
crazy I sell you know what don't you
love me Julia I'm pretty sure I told you
that I loved you before oh my god that
is not what I mean and you know it David
it has been six months and we haven't
even you know we haven't
[Music]
SAP's
we haven't had sex how many times can we
go over this we've already talked about
this I've already told you that I'm not
ready to go that far yet
so I don't understand why you have to
pressure me so much because it's been
months David I have knees and for your
information
most men would pounce on this yeah Oh
what this really for your information
most women appreciate the fact when a
man respects her body yes respect but
you haven't even tried to touch me
which makes me feel like you don't want
me not to mention that raises a few
questions a few questions like what go
ahead
fine are you gay is there a question
mark in your pants what does that even
mean I use your penis curve like
question marks do you confuse like it
doesn't know what it is I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you I swear to god you know it's
not small at this moment no it's not
small is it'll do the job just find you
oh my god
get you ass up right now and let's go
look I don't get it either
but either way the baby's coming whether
you like it or not and how impossible it
sounds it's going to happen so don't
don't say free [ __ ] mark
haemorrhoid I gotta go
that your mom yeah how'd she take it
how do you think she took it we again
with the we what do you mean with this
is all your fault
excuse me forgive me you are me this is
all ya gonna sit there and blame all
this on me oh yes I am gonna play this
all on you because it's all your fault
you couldn't keep your hands to yourself
and in case of unification you just had
to get a piece I will slap the [ __ ] out
of you yo hands off of me crappy good I
don't care because once again all on you
I wasn't ready and you just had to force
me go take my flower
first stop calling your virginity of
flower you sound like a [ __ ]
second you overreacting I'm overreacting
what are you doing if it can you - ahaha
yeah I don't want any bother right now
if you don't mind I just want to get
back to my iPad you please pull around a
little bit mm-hmm what is that hair huh
lord give me the strength please Jesus
have mercy honey
platypus face for John ellipse I don't
want to be touched
right now communique feel are you gonna
be like this for the rest of your
pregnancy cuz if you are I swear to god
I'll leave you oh you are going to leave
you're gonna leave your pregnant
boyfriend well ain't that about a [ __ ]
I get it you're pregnant I get it
how long can write that up for huh how
long three months until the baby done
pops out my belly like a pump I watch it
ah okay so enjoy good days David wait
til that baby pops out see how fast I
need to kick it with a dick oh my god
here we go and you know since we're
gonna go ahead and do is let's do this
you have never been supportive of MA
that's right ever since I have been
pregnant I feel as if I've been going
through this pregnancy all by myself and
for your information just in case you
didn't care
my ankles are swollen my kneecaps hurt
my breasts have quite developed and my
areolas have been getting large okay and
yeah lately I feel
[Music]
you were fat before your pregnancy you
know what look I'm you know I'm really
sexually frustrated right now yeah
can you please tell me what's been going
on with you lately I honestly I don't
know you anymore I'm scared
I know you're scared but everyone is
before they give birth that's
understandable don't understand what I'm
talking about how do I explain this
you're a woman right are you asking me
if I'm not woman just now that's not
what I'm saying
physically I don't know where the baby's
coming out from do you you don't even
think about it did you because I have no
[Applause]
yeah of course you did we be shown and
says the [ __ ] I I don't have a vagina
Julie calm down honey we're gonna figure
this out no no I am don't tell me how to
feel right now okay because you if you
gonna come up a booty hole for my peepee
and it's gonna tear me in half like
Shaq's penis I don't going on oh my god
David no no I
[Music]
[Music]
you